I'm sorry, but I was allowed to possess Vertex.  You
can read my movements After all, you're
just a villager Did you really
think you
could beat me?  You've exploded your adventure, right? A
battle of good things is probably unavoidable, right?
Then it's time for master to come in. Tell your whereabouts with a communication device.  Give it
to me
Remote surgery
can make all the zombies you control use the same magic It's a massive attack like this It
looks like you've got your hands full with regeneration Is it all that Elle had?  It
was a mistake that I didn't drop it
[music] I guess he
can't move now I can definitely hit him, but just in case I'll
kill him with maximum firepower
This is the end